Multiplying x squared in this function, by a number greater than 1, makes it
grow taller. So this is a vertical stretch. We can see this happening here in
the equation y equals 2 x squared. On the graph of y equals x squared we get
the point 2, 4, but on the graph of y equals 2 x squared, we got the point 2,
8. It's not quite on our graph but you can tell this has been stretched upward
by a factor of 2. This graph is taller than this one. Now on the other hand, if
we multiply x squared instead by a number that is still positive but is less
than one, then the graph will be vertically shrunk. Like this graph, y equals 1
half x squared. Here instead of the 0.24 that we see on this graph, we have the
0.2,2. It's only half as tall.